[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: OK, so let's
continue with our discussion
about continuous
functions, no pun intended.
First, let me
recall a few facts.
Well, this is not a definition.
But this was a theorem
we proved last time.
So I won't recall the
definition of continuity.
But we proved this theorem
characterizing continuity.
And if we have a subset
of R, an element in S,
and a function f going from S
to R, then f is continuous at C
if and only if for
every sequence x sub n,
we have elements of S such
that xn converges to C.
We have limit as
n goes to infinity
if x sub n equals
f of C. So this was
a theorem we proved last time.
And let me recall an older
theorem, which I said
was very powerful, but
never really gave you
any powerful
application, which we'll
start giving some
powerful applications now.
But this was the
Bolzano-Weierstrass theorem,
which states that every bounded
sequence of real numbers
has a convergent sub-sequence.
And we're going to use
these two theorems today
and in the next lecture to
prove that a continuous function
on a closed and bounded
interval is very well-behaved.
So what we're going to show,
let's call it the theme,
is that so if f from a
closed and bounded interval
is continuous, meaning it's
continuous at every point,
then it is well-behaved.
And for example, the first
thing that we're going to prove,
this will be a combination
of two theorems,
is that the image of a
closed and bounded interval
by a continuous function is
another closed and bounded
interval.
And E could equal D. So this
could just be a single point.
For example, if f is
a constant function,
then the image would
just be a single point.
So this is a theme of this
lecture and the next lecture.
And so, let's start.
Basically, we're going
to prove two theorems.
One is called the
min-max theorem,
and the other is called
Bolzano's intermediate value
theorem.
The min-max theorem will tell
you that f of an interval
is always contained in
an interval of this type.
And then the intermediate
value theorem
will tell you everything in
between two certain bounds
is attained by f.
So let's start off with showing
that f of a closed and bounded
interval is a bounded set.
So let me just
recall what it means
for a function to be bounded.
We say that a function from
a subset S to R is bounded.
So here, S is a subset of R--
is bounded if there exists
a non-negative B such
that for all x and S, f of x
is bigger than or equal to B.
So for example, if I take
f of x to be 3x plus 1.
And here, S is closed and
bounded interval 0, 1,
then f is bounded.
So pictorially,
what does this mean?
Well, f of x equals 3x plus 1.
So at 1, it's going to be 4.
And pictorially, a
function is bounded
if the graph is always bounded
between two real numbers.
And for us, for f of x, it's
always bounded between 0 and 4
in terms of this absolute value.
So f of x equals 3x plus 1.
This is less than or
equal to by the triangle
inequality 3 times the
absolute value of x plus 1.
X is between 0 and 1.
So it's absolute
value is bounded by 1.
So this function is bounded.
And so, how about a function
which is not bounded?
What does that mean?
Remember, whenever
we see a definition,
we should try to negate it
to understand it better.
So f is unbounded if for all
B bigger than or equal to 0,
there exists some bad x such
that f of x in absolute value
is bigger than or equal to B.
So if a bounded
function is supposed
to have a graph bounded
between two real numbers,
an unbounded one is one in
which at least part of the graph
is going off to plus
infinity or minus infinity.
So most basic example
we could think of
is, let's say if we wanted
to go from 0, 1 to R. Again,
we could take f of x to be
well, 0 at x equals 0, 1 over x
if x is not equal to 0.
So this function
looks like 1, 1,
and goes up to infinity as
you approach x equals 0.
So why is this unbounded?
We have to verify the
negation of the definition.
So claim f is unbounded.
Let B be bigger
than or equal to 0.
We now have to find an x
in 0, 1, so that 1 over x--
or so that f of x is bigger
than B. And this is pretty easy.
So let x be in R such that
1 over x is bigger than B.
So if B is equal to 0, we
take x to be anything in 0, 1.
That's fair enough-- i.e.
x [? less than ?] 1
over B. So if we like,
we could make this explicit.
So I'll just keep it here.
And so, now if we take x
here and look at the graph,
it's going to be bigger
than B. And that's it.
So several of these proofs will
have the same flavor of what
we're going to try and prove.
And this one is a nice one to
start off with, and necessary.
So my first theorem
that I want to prove
about continuous functions
on a bounded interval--
closed and bounded interval--
is that they're bounded.
So if I have a function from
a, b to R is continuous,
meaning it's continuous
at every point in a, b,
then f is bounded.
So the proof of this theorem,
and several of these theorems,
will be by contradiction.
And the fact that we're on the
closed and bounded interval
is--
or that we're in
this setting is what
allows us to use
Bolzano-Weierstrass,
this powerful tool.
So this is-- so assume
and, so like I said,
this proof is by contradiction,
that the conclusion is false.
Which the precise
meaning is right here.
For all b, there exists
an x and S such that that.
So for every b, I
can find an x and S
so that the absolute
value of f of x
is bigger than or equal to b.
So I could take b to
be N, for example,
where N as a natural number.
Then for all N,
a natural number,
so I'm taking b to be N, there
exists x sub n in a, b, such
that f of x sub n
in absolute value
is bigger than or equal to n.
So now I have this
sequence, which
is bounded because it's in this
closed and bounded interval.
Then xn is bounded, because
it's in this closed and bounded
interval a, b.
So by Bolzano-Weierstrass,
there exists a subsequence
x in sub k, of the sequence
x sub n and x in R, such
that limit as k goes to infinity
of x of n sub k equals x.
Now, I claim that this x is
actually in the interval a, b.
Since x of n sub
k is a subsequence
of x sub n, which are
in a sub b, or a comma
b, so I have for all k x sub
n sub k is between a and b.
This implies by what we
know about limits that
limits respect inequalities.
And therefore, a is less
than or equal to limit
as k goes to infinity of x sub
n sub k, which is less than
or equal to b.
And this is x.
So i.e.
x is between a and b.
Another way, instead of
going through this is,
I believe we did
in the assignment,
that an interval of
this form is closed.
And you proved that
for a closed set--
so when I say an interval
of this form is closed,
I mean it's a closed set.
And you proved on the
assignment that for a closed
set, if I have a
convergent sequence,
then the limit of that sequence
has to belong to the set.
So this is really a
consequence of the fact
that this interval
is a closed set.
So I have this
subsequence x sub n sub k.
It's converging to
x, which is in a, b.
And I know the function.
I haven't used
anything about f yet.
And I'm assuming
it's continuous.
So let's look at f of x.
Since f is continuous,
and the x sub n sub
k is converged to x as k goes to
infinity, I know by the theorem
up top over there, that f
of x equals the limit of f
of x sub n sub k.
And therefore, the
absolute value of x
is equal to the limit
as k goes to infinity
of the absolute values.
But now, f of x sub n is always
bigger than or equal to n.
That's how the x
of n's were chosen.
We assume that f is
unbounded, and therefore,
all of these x sub n's in a, b
were chosen so that f of x sub
n is bigger than or equal to n.
So this is bigger
than or equal to--
so each of these is bigger
than or equal to n sub k.
Let's see, how to
write this without--
OK.
So we'll write it this way.
I don't want to write
the limit of something
equals infinity,
because we haven't
said what it means for the limit
of something to equal infinity.
So then, the limit
as k goes to infinity
of f of x sub n sub k
exists, which implies
that the sequence is bounded.
A convergent sequence
is always bounded.
And since n sub k is always less
than or equal to f of x sub k,
and this is a bounded
sequence, this
tells me that the sequence
n sub k is bounded.
But this is impossible.
Remember, to form a
subsequence, the n sub k's
are increasing integers,
which is a contradiction.
And this is always because n sub
1, is always less than n sub 2,
is less than n 3, and so on.
So these are always getting
bigger without bound.
And therefore, we have
our contradiction.
So again, here's the
structure of the proof.
We want to assume
some property of f.
So we assume not.
We get this kind of bad sequence
of numbers in this interval.
And using Bolzano-Weierstrass,
we get to pass to some limit x.
And the continuity of f at x
essentially breaks the badness
of this sequence x sub n.
And we'll see another
argument where
it's kind of the same flavor.
So we'll soon
state that f always
achieves a maximum
value and minimum value.
So let me first on the closed
and bounded intervals-- so
let me precisely define
what these absolute mins
and absolute maxes are.
So let f be a function
from S to R. S
is a non-empty subset of R.
We say, f achieves
an absolute max.
Let me write it this way--
an absolute min at
c in S if f of c
sits below f of x for all x in
S. If for all x in S, f of c
is less than or equal to f of x.
So this is an absolute min.
f achieves absolute max
at d and S if f of d
sits above everything.
Every x you stick into
f, if for all x in S,
f of x is less than
or equal to f of d.
So for example.
So what's the picture
that goes with this?
Let's imagine we're on a
closed and bounded interval.
Then d-- so f achieves
absolute max at d.
The graph of f sits
below the value f of d.
And sits above the value f of c.
Now, absolute max
and mins at points
are so that the
function is always
sitting above f
evaluated at that point.
Just a quick Warning.
Let's say, we're looking at--
all right, so this
is not to scale.
But let's say our
function looks like this.
So this is one,
two, three halves.
Then, this function does
not have an absolute max,
does not achieve
an absolute max,
or achieve an absolute
min on the set 1, 2.
What you would like to say is
that f achieves an absolute min
at 1.
But the graph does not sit
above f evaluated at 1.
Just like over
here, the graph of f
does not sit below
f evaluated at 2.
So absolute f achieves an
absolute min at a point
if the whole graph sits above
f evaluated at that point,
not necessarily some number,
it sits below the whole graph.
That's what boundedness means.
So I just want to clarify that
distinction between the graph
of a function being bounded
below by a number and f
achieving a min at
a certain point.
So for example, the
graph of this function
is bounded below by 1.
But f does not achieve an
absolute min at c equals 1.
So our next theorem
is the min-max theorem
for continuous functions,
which is the following.
Let f be a function from a,
b to R. If f is continuous,
meaning it's continuous
at every point in a,b,
then f achieves absolute min
and absolute max on a, b.
So another way of stating
this, so let's just
make this a remark, it says that
they there exists c, d, and a,
b, such that f of a, b is
contained in f of c, f of d.
So we'll do the proof
of an absolute max.
And the proof of the absolute
min, I'll leave to you.
It's a simple change
in the argument that's
not too difficult.
And again, we're
going to use this powerful
tool, Bolzano-Weierstrass,
that allows us to go from an
arbitrary sequence in a, b,
to a convergent subsequence.
So this equals f from a to b--
let me write it this way.
If this function is continuous,
then by what we've proven--
where?
Over there.
This implies f is bounded.
Then the set E given
by the range of f,
so f of x, where x is in a,
b, this set is bounded above.
If the absolute value
of f of x is always
less than or equal
to some b, then
f of x is always bounded
above by b for all x and a, b.
So this set is bounded above.
Now, let L be the
supremum of E, which
exists, because the real
numbers have the least upper
bound property.
Whenever we have a non-empty
subset which is bounded above,
we can always find a supremum.
Now, since L is a supremum of
this set, we did this, I think,
in an assignment.
Yes, I definitely
did an assignment.
Then there exists a
sequence of elements
of this set E converging
to L. And to express
that, that means there exists
some sequence of elements.
So there exists a
sequence of the form
f of x sub n such that
limit as n goes to infinity
of f of x sub n equals L.
Now, we would like to
show that L is equal to f
of d for some number d.
And how we're going to do
that is, well, this is--
the x sub n's are just
some sequence in a, b.
So we can pass to a subsequence,
which converges to some number,
call it d.
And then we need to show
that f of d equals L.
And that's where
we use continuity.
And then, that's
the whole proof.
Which we saw a
little bit over here.
We passed a subsequence.
And then we get to say that
the limit of this subsequence
has the same property as
the original sequence.
So by Bolzano-Weierstrass, there
exists a subsequence x sub n
sub k.
So this is a subsequence
of the sequence x sub n.
And as before, the
same argument and limit
d, but as before, d
will be in the set a, b,
such that limit as k goes
to infinity of x of n sub k
equals d.
So we use
Bolzano-Weierstrass to pass
to a subsequence
of the x sub n's,
and a convergent subsequence.
And yeah, so, all of these x sub
n sub k's are between a and b.
So their limit d will
be between a and b.
But now, since f
is continuous at d,
it's continuous at
every point in a, b.
So it's certainly continuous
at d-- f of d, this
is equal to the limit
as k goes to infinity
of f of x of n sub
k, since the x of n
sub k's are converging to d.
And now, f of x
sub n sub k, this
is also a subsequence of
the sequence f of x sub n.
And f of x sub n is a
convergent sequence.
So any subsequence has to
converge to the same thing.
Since f of x sub n converges
to L, and f of n sub k,
k is a subsequence
of f of x sub n.
And remember, what was L?
L was the sup of V. And
therefore, for all x in a,
b, f of x is less than or
equal to f of d, which means f
achieves an absolute max at d.
And the absolute min is similar.
And I'll leave it to you.
So just rerunning
through the proof.
We did use the fact that a
continuous function is bounded.
And we extracted the sup, if
you like, of the range of f.
And so, which is by this
exercise we did in one
of the assignments, means
that this supremum is equal
to the limit of f of x sub n's.
We would like to show L is
equal to f of d for some d.
So we passed a subsequence
of the x sub n's.
That does converge to
something in the interval a, b.
And we can show using
the continuity of f.
And how this original sequence
was chosen, that f at that
point is actually equal to
the supremum of that set.
And therefore, f achieves
an absolute max at that set.
As beginning
students of math, one
of the things we
should be curious about
is what hypotheses are
needed and what are not
in the statements of theorems.
So our main hypothesis--
so we had two hypotheses
really in the theorem,
that f is going from this closed
and bounded interval to R,
and that f is continuous.
So what happens if we drop
one of those hypotheses?
Is the conclusion still true,
that f achieves an absolute max
and absolute min?
So this example that
I drew right here
shows that we need to have the
function be continuous in order
for it to achieve
an absolute max
and absolute min on the
closed and bounded interval.
But it also needs to be on a
So we have some
continuous function from S
to R. Can we drop
the assumption that S
is equal to this closed
and bounded interval?
Meaning could it be,
say, an open interval?
Does the same conclusion hold?
I.e.
let's say f is from
an open interval.
And the answer is, no.
Simple example is, if I take
the function f of x equals,
for example, 1 over x,
minus 1 over 1 minus x.
And on the open
interval 0, 1, so what
does this guy look like?
Here's 0.
Let me draw a dotted line there.
Here's 1.
And the graph shoots
up to positive infinity
as you approach 0 and
as you approach 1.
So where does it equal 0?
I guess there's 1/2.
So this function
does not achieve
a absolute min or absolute max.
But it is continuous
on this interval.
But because the interval
is not closed and bounded,
this function does not
achieve an absolute min
or absolute max.
So what I'm trying to say is
that the assumptions that two--
so there's two assumptions
here, that we're
working on a closed
and bounded interval,
and that f is continuous.
These two assumptions are
necessary for the theorem
to be true.
Now, they are not
the most precise way
of stating this theorem.
You could replace a closed
and bounded interval
with what's called a compact
set, which maybe I'll
put in the assignment
or on the midterm,
depending on where there's room.
But just in the
setting of intervals,
the interval has to
be closed and bounded.
And the function has to be
continuous for this theorem
to hold true.
So that's what I
wanted to get at.
So what we've proven, as I
said in this remark here,
is that there exists two
numbers c and d in a, b,
so that f of a, b is
contained in f of c, f of d.
c would be where f
achieves an absolute min.
d would be where if f
achieves an absolute max.
And this is absolute max.
So now the question becomes,
do I hit everything in between?
Does this inclusion
become equality?
And I gave the game away at
the beginning of the lecture
by saying, yes, it will.
But that's actually a theorem.
So this was the min-max theorem,
which I didn't call it that.
I should have.
It's actually called
that in the notes.
But now we're going to move
on to the intermediate value
theorem.
And first we're going to do
what looks like a special case,
and then we'll prove
the general case.
So this theorem,
which I'm actually--
it's not called this
in the textbook.
But I'm going to call it this,
which I'll call the bisection
method, is the following.
Let f be a function from a, b
to R if f of a is less than 0--
and so, I need one more--
be continuous.
So we're always in
the continuous setting
for this section.
So if f of a is less than 0
and f of b is bigger than 0,
then there exists c and E in the
interval a, b such that f of c
equals 0.
So the picture that goes on
with goes along with this is,
here's a, b.
Here's f of a.
f of b is positive.
And therefore, if
it's continuous,
and you believe the
definition of a continuity
is the fact that is
that I don't have
to pick up my piece of chalk.
It pains me to say this.
But that's, again, not
the official definition,
but one you keep in your head.
Since somebody probably
told you that at some point,
if I don't have to pick
up my piece of chalk,
then eventually, I have
to cross the x-axis.
And therefore, at this
point c, f of c will be 0.
Now, why do I call this
theorem the bisection method?
As we'll see, the way you
determine this c is by what
in calculus books is called
the bisection method.
So for the proof,
let-- we're going
to define a sequence
of numbers a in b
and with special properties.
So I'm first going to tell
you what a1 and b1 are.
a1 is just going to be
a, b1 is going to be b.
And so, now I'm
going to tell you
how to choose the next element
in the sequence knowing
the element in the
sequence before.
So we're going to--
first to find two
sequences a n and bn.
So let me tell you
how to do that.
And the way we're
going to choose this
is so that f of a sub n
is always less than 0,
and f of b sub n is always
bigger than or equal to 0.
And there obtained from
the previous two guys
by taking the midpoint, so
bisecting the ones before.
So to get this started, a1
will be just a, b1 will be b.
Now, for in a natural number,
we're going to define--
so we know a1.
So now, I'm going to
tell you how to define a2
based on now you know a1.
But what I'm about to
write down will also
tell you how to define a3,
since you now know how to do a2.
So I'm going to
write it this way.
For in a natural
number, knowing a sub n,
b sub n, we define a sub n
plus 1 and b sub n plus 1 as
follows.
So if f of a sub n plus
b sub n-- so the midpoint
between the two
guys that I already
know-- so if you like, take n
to be 1 for when you first read
how to define a sub 2, say.
But what I'm writing
down applies to every in.
So we take f of a sub n
plus b sub n over 2 to be,
if this is bigger
than or equal to 0,
then we define a sub n
plus 1 to be a sub n,
and b sub n plus 1
to be the midpoint.
And if of the midpoint
is less than 0,
then a sub n plus 1 is going
to be the midpoint, and b sub n
plus 1 will be the
previous point.
So let me-- in fact,
so this is how you
define the sequence in general.
Let's walk through what
this means just for n
equals 2 so that you see--
you get the idea.
Maybe I should have
done this first.
So let's draw a picture to go--
in fact, I don't need this axis.
I'll just-- b.
So and this is a sub
1, this is b sub 1.
And then, we look
at the midpoint.
So we know that f of a
sub 1 is less than 0.
f of b sub 1 is
bigger than 0, which
is certainly bigger
than or equal to 0
if it's bigger than 0.
Now we look at the midpoint.
And based on the
sign of this guy
will be how we define a2 and b2.
So for the sake of me
going through this,
Let's suppose that f of
this thing is less than 0.
Then I take, a2 will
be a1 plus b1 over 2.
And b2 will be b1.
And now, I look at the
midpoint of these two guys.
So now, I'm at this stage, f
of a2 is less than 0, f of b2
is bigger than 0.
So I'm in the picture
before, except now I'm
at half the distance
between the two endpoints.
And so, I look at this point
now, a2 plus V2 over 2.
And I look at the sign of that.
And let's suppose
f of this thing
is bigger than or equal to 0.
Then I will take
this point to be a 3,
and this point will now be b3.
And what I have is f of
a3 is less than 0, f of b3
is bigger than or equal to 0.
So the point is that the left
endpoint is always negative
when I stick it into f.
The right endpoint is
always non-negative
when I stick it into f.
And that the distance
between the two midpoints
is always getting cut in half
by the previous distance before.
But we're always in the picture,
but kind of in the setting
we were in the step before.
Now, we have three properties of
this sequence of a n's and bn's
So for all n, they're
always bounded
between the original
two endpoints.
Not only that, the a sub n's
are always moving to the right.
Remember, a sub n
is always getting
replaced by the midpoint between
a sub n and b sub n, possibly,
or staying the same.
So a sub n is always less than
or equal to a sub n plus 1.
So in fact, let me
write it this way.
We always have a sub n is
less than or equal to b sub n.
We always have a is less than
or equal to a n plus 1, which
is less than or equal to a n.
And then, we also have--
so for all in b.
I'm making a mess of
what I'm writing down.
So let's start this over.
So the first property
I want to write,
for all N natural numbers,
we have b, a sub n
is always less than or
equal to a sub n plus 1.
And b sub n plus 1,
remember, whenever--
if we're going to
change b, it's always
to change it to the midpoint
between the previous guy
and the a from
the previous step.
So this is always less
than or equal to b sub n.
And now, two, if I
look at the difference,
this is always equal to 1/2
of the previous distance.
Because either one
of these are getting
changed to the midpoint.
So if it's a sub
n plus 1, then b
sub n plus 1 minus a sub n plus
1, is b sub n minus a sub n
plus b sub n over 2,
which gives me this.
Three, for all n,
a natural number--
and this is just based
on how we are choosing--
we are doing this construction,
f of a sub n is less than 0,
and f of b sub n is
bigger than or equal to 0.
So I hope this is clear.
All of these, if you like,
you could prove by induction.
For equals 1, this
is certainly true.
Assume it holds for
n equals m, and then
prove all of these statements
here for n equals m plus 1.
But I'm just stating it as
clear from the construction,
and hopefully it is.
So what does this give us?
Well, by one, the
sequence is a sub n
and b sub n are bounded,
because they're always
bounded between a and
b monotone sequences.
a sub n is increasing,
b sub n is decreasing.
Thus, there exists limits.
So I'm going to
call them c and d.
But it has nothing to do with
the c and d from over here.
Thus these sequences converge.
I.e, there exists
element c and d in a, b,
such that limit as n goes to
infinity of a sub n equals c--
again, the a sub n's and b
sub n's are between a and b.
So their limits will
also be between a and b--
b sub n equals d.
Now, I claim c equals d.
Why should this not
come as a surprise?
Well, the a n's and bn's
are getting very close.
They're always-- the distance
between any two of them
is always getting halved.
Now, a sub m minus b sub n,
this equals a sub n minus 1,
minus b sub n minus 2 over 2,
which equals 1 over 2 squared,
a sub n minus 2, minus b sub
n minus 2, dot, dot, dot.
And therefore, this equals
1 over 2n minus 1 b sub 1
minus a sub 1, equals 1 over
2 to the n minus 1, b minus a.
And therefore, c minus d,
which is equal to the limit
as n goes to infinity
of a sub n minus
b sub n equals the limit as n
goes to infinity of 1 over 2
to the n minus 1, b minus a.
1 over 2 to the n minus
1 is converging to 0,
times this fixed number,
b minus a, equals 0.
And therefore, these two
numbers, these two limits
c and d equal each other.
So this step here is by
the second property here.
And now, we're essentially done.
Using the third property,
by three and continuity,
if I look at f of c, since the
a sub n's are converging to c,
this is equal to--
and f of a sub n is
always less than 0.
So its limit is less
than or equal to 0.
And now, remember, c is also
equal to the limit of the b sub
n's.
And therefore, by continuity, f
of c is equal to f of b sub n.
And the f of b sub n's
are always non-negative.
So their limit is also
bigger than or equal to 0.
So I've shown that
this number f of c
is less than or equal
to 0, and that it's also
bigger than or equal to 0.
And therefore, f of c equals 0.
So we use the--
why I put the
bisection method here
is because we used
a bisection method
to prove this
theorem, which looks
like a kind of a special case
of a certain intermediate value
property.
Meaning that I can always find
something, that if I have--
that I can always find
something in the interval that
achieves something in
between f of a and f of b.
In this case, it's just 0.
But I can in fact upgrade this.
This is the following
theorem due to Bolzano
so Bolzano's intermediate
value theorem.
Let f from a to b,
R be continuous.
If y is between f of b--
so meaning, let's say, so
we're in one of two cases.
Let's say f of a is
less than f of b.
If y is between f
of a and f of b,
then there exists a c in a,
b, such that f of c equals y.
If f of a is, say,
bigger than f of b,
and we take
something in between,
the same conclusion holds.
So in short, if I take
anything between the value
of the function evaluated at
the two endpoints a and b,
then the function achieves
that value at some point.
So if I take any
y between here, f
has to cross this
horizontal line.
And it's achieved
at some point c.
And we'll deduce this from--
so this looks like a special
case of this intermediate value
theorem, if f of a is less than
0, f of b is bigger than 0,
and y is equal to 0.
But in fact, you can reduce
this general statement
to that special case
just by a simple trick.
So proof, suppose f of
a is less than f of b.
So we're in this first case.
And y is in f of a, f of b,
let g of x be f of x minus y.
This is not a
function of x and y. y
is a fixed number between
f of a and f of b.
And this is a function
going from f to b to R,
and which is continuous.
So sum of two continuous
functions is continuous,
f is a continuous
function by assumption.
This is just a constant minus y.
So their sum is also continuous.
But now, if we look
at g of a, this
is equal to f of a minus y.
Now, y is bigger than f of a,
since y is in f of a, f of b.
So this is less than 0.
And g of b is equal to f of
b minus y is bigger than 0.
And therefore, by
the previous theorem,
there exists a c in
a, b, such that g of c
equals 0, which means i.e.
f of c equals y.
And the proof, assuming f
of a is bigger than f of b
is similar, you just now
put y here minus f of x.
Or you put-- now you define g
of x would be y minus f of x.
So let me just make
a remark about that.
Is similar, look at g of
x equals y minus f of x.
So Bolzano's intermediate
value theorem tells us
that if I take any value
between the function evaluated
at the two endpoints, then that
value is achieved by something
in between a and b.
And therefore, this will, in
fact, give us that f of a, b
is equal to f of c, f
of d for some c and d.
So this is a simple
theorem from this.
Is continuous if
f local n at c--
not local, absolute min
at c and absolute max
at d, then the image by f of a,
b is equal to f of c, f of d.
And what's the proof?
Well, apply Bolzano's
intermediate value theorem
to f now going from the
possibly smaller interval, c, d.
It could be d, c or
c, d, depending on
if the thing that I have to
stick in to f to get the min
and the thing I have to
stick into f to get the max
is smaller than the other.
So apply the Bolzano's
intermediate value theorem
to this function
now just restricted
to the smaller closed interval.
It's still continuous.
And that's the proof.
So maybe I was a little
too fast with that.
So let me just say a couple
of more words about this.
So this tells me that everything
between the two values
f of c and f of d is achieved
by f on this interval.
But this is a possibly
smaller interval than a, b.
So this is contained
in the range of f now
of f of this larger interval.
And since we already
know that f of a, b
is contained in f of c,
f of d, and now we've
proven the reverse
inclusion, this
implies that f of c, f
of d equals f of a, b.
And that's the proof.
So I think we'll stop there.
Next time, we'll finish
with a few remarks
about an application of the
intermediate value theorem.
And then we'll move on
to uniform continuity.